le festival musical ouverture prend ses
quartiers à la maison jean monnet à
bazoches sur guyonne le site qui
accueille d'habitude plutôt des
événements liés à la vie du père
fondateur de l'europe décidé d'élargir
son offre à la culture
pour nous c'est important d'ouvrir la
maison jean monnet qui est un site du
parlement européen qui est donc là pour
tous les citoyens de l'ouvrir aussi à la
culture aux arts et à la musique qui est
un vecteur de rapprochement des peuples
et des peuples d'europe pour la deuxième
édition du festival une soixantaine de
spectacles en plein air sont organisés
en ile-de-france par la fedis la
fédération des ensembles vocaux ou
instrumentaux spécialisés avec le
soutien de la région
l'année dernière ça avait été créée
justement un peu dans le cadre du du
contexte
duco vide pour proposer aux artistes de
renouer avec le public en extérieur dans
des cadres qui n'avaient pas l'habitude
d'accueillir des spectacles pour la
première date à la maison jean monnet
c'était le spectacle mythe de la
compagnie in et l'ensemble pulcinella
présenté le samedi 31 juillet un mélange
de musique baroque de danse et de textes
[Musique]
il
ça a été un moment très agréable on a
été très bien reçue le public aussi on
se rend compte qu'ils sont réceptives
non seulement aux textes ils sont
réceptifs aussi à la musique et à la
danse et et on sent les changes aussi
avec le public et ça ça c'est ça c'est
ça c'est super pour des artisans
deux autres dates sont prévues le 19 et
le 21 août de nouveaux spectacles à
découvrir dans le jardin de la maison
jean monnet